bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovi do io sono fuori j
oggi giochiamo ad redoubt un indie
horror che mi avete consigliato i
tantissimi anche questo è come sapete i
videogame che mi consigliate veramente
in tanti sono quelli che faccio senza
neanche guardare che cosa sono
quindi siccome cat mario se devo essere
sincero non ho idea di che cosa sto per
andare cioè so che horror quindi più
mergo ok c'è una gnocca perfetto si
parte se questa protagonista non mi
dispiace
linda melinda già scritto sulla poppa
destra va bene ok se c'è un cellulare
che buongiorno c6 svegliata senza motivo
in un posto scuro niente di nuovo finora
rispetto a tutti di cazzo di videogame
indie horror che andiamo a giocare ci si
sveglia puntualmente in un posto senza
sapere come ci si è arrivati ovviamente
devo andare tipo o che ci si muove
normalmente perfetto alla notevole ma
che cazzo di posto è questa mi sembra
una capanna vietnamita abbandonata da un
bel po di tempo sarà ed era bono non si
capisce cos'è cos'è quello a perfetto è
il telefono devono raccolto previsto è
perfetto mai è un iphone non è che no
non so che cos'è cos'hai incoming col
perfetto sia una chiamata pronto pizza
ok che cazz successo non oca perché c'è
la fotocamera raga troppo figo questa
roba
ok questo non me l'aspettavo
c'è un c'era ok girati attenta che cazzo
c'era un fantasma nella fotocamera c'è
ma non ho capito vede i fantasmi
attraverso il telefono c'è tipo tra
l'altro mentre mi sposto vedo telefono
che inquadra una figata assurda ma posso
tipo asi perfetto
no che è figo non avesse veramente bella
ragazza una cosa ma c'era un fantasma di
prima posso farti qualche le foto se
devo praticamente penso che sto gioco
sia concentrato sul trovare i fantasmi
tramite il cellulare c'è una roba del
genere va bè io esco permesso il posto è
veramente paradisiaco non mi aspettavo
di meglio buongiorno a te ho trovato un
telefono e suo si mette in posa
ok questa la metto su facebook la targa
è se si metteva in posa migliore magari
era meglio doveva che cazzo successo gli
ha preso il mal di testa moment a te
passa tutto
oddio diventato tutto che cazzo ne dice
il tratto buio pesto
ok
merda madonna che ambienta ma silent
hill gli fa una bocca sto gioco
veramente madonna raga non si vede
niente buio per veramente senza il
cellulare sarei perso c'è tipo non so
neanche spiega con mio zio
io io me ne me ne vado è mai stato un
piacere
adesso però no veramente la grecia paura
che mi scusi qualcuno davanti non lo
vedo devo tipo ce non allora accesso
telefono che che cazzo mi sta seguendo
via via via via via via via via via via
via ok ok bene mi sta seguendo aiuto
non lo so oddio no ok ok ok mi sta
prendendo una lezione che orly aiuto
d'ora ok ok ok ok ok ok via via sono
riuscito a scappare
che culo bene non è pià non è piacevole
come inizio devo a mi sta ancora
seguendo
io veramente c'è una paura matta che mi
spunti da un momento all'altro devo
cos'è questo c'è un buco nel muro non
avevo visto devo ok non c'è un buco nel
mondo che cazzo succede mi stanno
trovando allora così c'è un buco così no
spiegatemi che cazzo devo fare tipo ok
addio e tipo il binario 9 trequarti
questo è fantastico
devo vado avanti io non sono anche che
cazzo sto facendo ma vado avanti c'è una
porta qui non si capisce una mazza ma
penso voglia dire state alla larga e noi
entriamo perfetto buongiorno
e non era mia intenzione ma devo entrare
devo entrare
ok che cazzo è un calabrone madonna
quanto è grosso che cazzo è un mio zio è
si è materializzato dopo che li ho fatto
una foto a sto punto è meglio che esca
perché non so c'è lì non c'è niente da
fare penso c'è un'altra porta perfetto
apriamo a vermezzo devo consegnare delle
pizze o un telefono porca [ __ ] è caduto
cos'è la tanica ma edizione chi cazzo è
stata avuta ragione ci sono dei disegni
fantastici sul muro c'è ancora una
perché ci sono le taniche d'acqua in
giro non l'ho capita sta cosa ragazza
edificio è veramente inquietante di the
grudge giuro
vabbè io direi di entrare in una liste
porta e qui perfetto questa si può
entrare
buongiorno c'è mica ok c'è c'è un
pupazzo impiccato fantastico perfetto
gli ho fatto anche una foto così per
ricordo eh no no perché chiude la porta
maledetta cioè una stanza inutile non mi
chiedete per buongiorno mia mi avvicino
mi avvicino molto mi sto avvicinando con
molta cautela sia calma le faccia
un'altra foto così almeno magari lei
sceglie quale mentre come profilo è ok
perfetto mi avvicina un po di più rosie
e dovrebbero nominarla miss sorriso
comunque
e devo ok c'è e sta scattando delle foto
da mezz'ora me fa chiedermi che cosa sto
facendo 2 mar ionio are not my friends
and we are two denaro allora dobbiamo
uscire di qua meglio questo allora
andiamo se vai fammi strada brutta
stronza devo si va bene allora andiamo
molto piano molto piano detto ferma
cazzo è scappata che [ __ ] non riesco
dovete essere andata c'è ma ma si può
non l'altro neanche più che bastarda che
lorito [ __ ] prima vi vuole
accompagnare poi se ne va va beh non
facciamo finta di niente
c'è una macchina è un po in disuso mi sa
però vabbè andiamo al piano di sopra sto
punto è l'unico punto dove non sono
ancora andato
salve e mica dove cazzo devo andare
mica è entrata nel cesso no questo
eccesso prima di tutto se ma perché ci
sono state che veramente fantastiche ok
perfetto
scusatemi ragazze perché non posso
vedere quanto sono sexy
scusatemi raga se ogni tanto controllo
col cellulare ma veramente mica go
sempre addosso perché ci ho paura di
incontrare qualcuno ma non importa va
bene noi andiamo avanti
sono tutte chiuse le porte meno che
l'ultima per me ok sei qui brutta stanza
così impari a scappare bastarda di merda
è cazzo stimoli mi conosco sono quelli
di the grudge maledizione io torno
indietro
bene se chiuso la porta che cazzo
successo dio
oddio aiuto aprite aprite cazzo ok ok ok
piano che cazzo è successo oh mio dio
questa è veramente pesante che cazzo
successo dove sono mi sta svegliando
tipo dove cazzo finita
oddio è stato che cazzo è sta roba raga
non ci sto capendo più niente
mi sembra sono morto cosa
devo devo andare avanti seguo la luce
perfetto oh mio dio è diventato
abbagliante maledizione cosa devo fare
qui e adesso non vedo più un cazzo
ok tutto ok perfetto si è scritto tutto
raga io non sto capendo che cosa succede
ok sono di nuovo sveglio perfetto sono
di nuovo in sostanza di merda
dov'è andato a finire la tipa maledetta
stronza
devo fatemi uscire di qualche sostanza
la già nate testo sembra quella di the
grudge chi giura identica bene io me ne
vado raga io sento qualcuno piangere in
lontananza non so se lo sentite perché
di solito abbasso l'audio quando ed i
tuoi video però vabbè c'è qualcuno che
sta piangendo comunque adesso vado a
vedere credo che provenga tipo di qua
non so neanch'io
ok cos'è quella roba laggiù è un gatto e
un gatto al city è quello di ragazzi the
grudge sto gioco porca [ __ ] e ci sono
troppi riferimenti allora salve
mica lei che piangeva vero ma lei ce
l'ha facebook no perché io sto facendo
foto un po in giro quindi magari tago
anche lei è perfetto
è una foto un po più da vicino se non le
dispiace ok cazzo sta si sta avvicinando
il gatto oddio inquietantissimo ragabo
rate di roba si è incazzato no vabbè io
alle cancello se non ti piacciono è
allora brutto stronzo te ne faccio di
più
non ho veramente raga inquietantissimo
sto gatto di merda mi sta seguendo
cosa devo fare devo andare di sotto
maledizione prima che mi raggiunga
magari ma se io provassero accarezzarti
mimì sacchi un braccio gatto nero porta
iella va bene non importa però devo ok
oh cazzo mi si sia alzato
ok bene non mi piace va bene così vado
via vado via vado via vado via
perfetto sento ombra che sento qualcuno
piangere viggiù reti ok che cazzo ci fai
più brutta stronza di merda è ok ti pago
anche qui così abbiano tutti ti deridono
perché piangi e cosa devo fare
ai clienti il display si guardano gli
one booking air adobe display york che
erano per te dischi elimina ok
praticamente devo prendere st chiave e
andarmene fuori dai [ __ ] perché lei
non può non chiedetemi perché hai la
chiave per la porta principale perfetto
senti un secondo io ti lascio molto
volentieri qui perché mi stai veramente
sul carso però c'è un gatto che che sta
scendendo e non avere intenzioni secondo
me quindi veditela tu comunque va beh io
esco di qua come cannes dove la porta
principale questa e quella sarà mica
quella di prima questa qui perfetto si
era questa è uscimmo a sto punto non so
bene che cosa dicono mai
ok c'è stato un lampo digiuno raga che
come posso non sarebbe neanche male se
fosse giorno però dovrebbe essere giorno
è ok è sparita la casa o mio dio dove
cazzo è finita la casa è rimasto il
divano solo maledizione va beh meglio
così almeno non rivedo più quella
stronza di merda quindi va bene perché
c'è una candela maledizione io vado
avanti
c'è c'è mica qualcuno qui dietro no vero
ok no perché la fip veramente la tipa
dell'inizio raga mi ha traumatizzato
beh io vado vado avanti mi sembra vi
sembra un cimitero vietnamita questo sì
raga sto gioco è molto atmosferico
veramente voglio provare l'art cioè
fatemi sapere ovviamente nei commenti se
volete che io quando uscirà il gioco
originale
se volete che lo faccia mi ero
dimenticato di dirvi che questa non era
la serie horror che volevo aprire questo
è un indie horror così un episodio a
caso di quelli che faccio random cazzo
sto andando non lo so più
che cazzo è sta roba ok c'è un gigante
un gigante veramente brutto però va beh
noi avviciniamoci buongiorno
sì questo governo vero anche senza
cellulare questo è strano
vabbè io tengo anche te comunque non ci
sta devo farti tre foto per riuscire a
farne una completa però titano in tutte
e tre infatti i tre profili diversi uno
per le gambe uno per il corpo e uno per
la testa
vabbè io perché ci sono delle candele
qui questo devo fare visto che non sei
così tanto socievole anche di fronte a
una bella gnocca un perché mi stai
guardando il culo pervertito io vabbè
comunque tornerei indietro perché non
c'è qui non mi pare si possa fare
non ho capito di preciso che cosa dovrei
fare
porca [ __ ] cos'è sta roba
aiuto aiuto o mio dio ma inizia la
madonna che cazzo ti faccio una forma
l'edizione ok sta bruciando non gli
piace essere fotografato credo
ok è appreso oddio chi cazzo è questo ce
n'è un altro mi stanno stuprando la
dizione no ai 8 quanti sono
no no ma quanti cazzo sono il caso è
successo
ebbene questa non era una cosa normale
non mi spiego che cos'è appena successo
c'erano dei tizi veramente brutti
e io vado di nuovo verso la luce che
palle che cazzo perché c'è un gatto se
sei tu quello di prima se molto più
carino bianco va bene è di tokyo messo
una gamba nel cranio però va bene lo
stesso ok io devo andare verso la luce
mi dispiace non posso farti compagnia
ok ragazzi sono di nuovo preparatevi
alla motta è ok ci siamo un gioco troppo
strada dove sono spero che non ci sia di
nuovo quel gigante di prima ok
come non detto ma sì così sono ovunque
cazzo ok devo farti 10mila foto credo
per un cazzo ok ok ok ok ok maledizione
edizione di sopra che cazzo ok forse se
ne va non lo sta scaldando
sta andando vista stop rende di nuovo
aiuto ok è bruciato
ok sta bruciando perfetto ok ragazzo rno
dov'ero prima perché presumo che si sia
sbloccato qualcosa credo perché se non
so come andare avanti c'è ok nostra
mente gigante lo vedo già la qui
comunque ci sarà un'altra strada ma
edizione come faccio ad andare avanti se
no le candele sono tutte accese già lo
vedo e quindi che cazzo ci dovevo
spegnere il mio compleanno
penso non so che cazzo deve fare
altrimenti c'è ok si aspetta la candela
quando ho fatto la foto è una è
un'applicazione ragazzi scarica
tranquillamente la l'app store permette
ti aiuta a spegnere le foto senza
soffiare devo riuscire a spegnerle tutti
insieme presumo ok perfetto che cazzo
succede adesso
e buon gioco cazzo no scusami non volevo
ok perfetto mi ha stuprato anche lui che
cazzo succede
buongiorno
sì sei veramente fuori di testa tu che
cazzo sto successo da fanno dietro quei
due
va bene c'è siamo in macchina siamo in
macchina non so perché era tutto un
sogno cioè fatemi capire era tutto un
sogno questo non l'ho capita sta cosa
ok che cazzo hai bevuto prima di
addormentarti farmi capire
to be continued sì mi fa piacere
sì questo ragazzo era era soltanto una
demo non era ovviamente no la serie
horror di cui vi parlavo che devo
iniziare quella inizierò la settimana
prossima se tutto va bene io direi che
per questo episodio posso chiuderla qui
come al solito servi dove è piaciuto
lasciate un commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook come in ogni video
trovate nella descrizione se non si
attaccò istinti iscrivetevi e noi ci
vediamo al prossimo video bella ragazzi